Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's welcome to module one of our stop fighting cancer course
Well, we're gonna go over some major pieces that you want to address as
Cancer patient or somebody who's trying not to become a cancer patient so that you can best take care of your body in
the most natural approach whether you still have to
Do some standards of care or not or you've exhausted that avenue
We have patients that come to us for all sorts of reasons many don't want to go the standards of care approach
And we understand that some have to because their cancers growing quickly. They want to add
integratively a natural approach and we understand that and
Some have not even thought about a natural slash alternative approach
And they went straight down the standards of care aisle, which is the most common thing to do
It's a very scary thing getting a cancer diagnosis and many people especially if they're not
regularly naturally minded in the first place
don't even
Have an open mind to natural things and tell a standards of care approach and the failing and
They are told that there's not a whole lot that they can do except maybe palliative chemo or something like that and
That doesn't interest them and they're now they're starting to look at natural things
Well, we want to be careful to use natural things
Wisely as well and this module I'm calling the natural band-aid approach
Because we can use natural things like a band-aid to still not really addressing the cause still not really addressing the reason
Why the person is in the state that they're in?
We're just going to use a bunch of natural things kind of the same way as you'd use medication and a lot of functional
Quote-quote functional medicine doctors or quote-unquote
naturopaths or quote-unquote
natural
Modalities really do that. They're they're maybe using
Nutraceuticals maybe using herbs maybe using vitamins or homeopathy, but still not digging in underneath the dig into the cause
They're still using it kind of like you'd use medicine. I have a headache. I'm gonna take some Tylenol
Well, don't take Tylenol take some white willow bark instead. Well, I guess it's better, you know, than doing drugs that have all these negative side effects
But shouldn't you dig in to find out why you have the headache in the first place?
Not that you wouldn't do those things not that you wouldn't
Still use some curcumin or white willow bark or buzzwelly or something for your headache
But we're still using it as a bandaid. We don't want to make that mistake
And that's really what this module's about to a natural bandaid approach can be the same as the medical bandaid approach
I guess there's nothing wrong with band-dates. You need to cover the wound. You need to deal with the symptoms at hand
But you need to find out why you did it if you're if you continue to put a band-aid on a wound because you're touching a hot
stove
And you don't stop touching the hot stove. We're gonna run out of band-dates pretty quick
Silly analogy, but we tend to do that in our medical system
That's really what the medical system is set up as you don't go to the medical doctor until you have a problem
And then they go there and they have a solution to that problem. Well currently in the last 50 years
The only solution to that problem is here take this drug as if you have a deficiency in a drug
Well natural care
Kindle and towards that too like I suggested and we don't want to
Just do that without finding out why the problem is there and looking for a solution by fixing the why
So you know one of our bottles and our clinic for years has been
Is been looking for the reason why there's always a reason why?
Well
Sometimes the reason why is
More difficult than other times to uncover
It's easy when you're touching a hot stove to know that well I'm touching the hot stove
That's why I burden myself. I guess I'll stop that
But when you have cancer or some serious disease like that
The reason why is a little bit more insidious to figure out so we need to do some digging and some testing to do that
But a natural approach a bad natural approach to a mandate approach is really not a whole lot different than a medical approach
There's benefits to mandates. There's sometimes you have to do surgery
When you're talking about cancer
Debaltine surgery sometimes can be extremely beneficial and can be necessary
Using chemotherapy can sometimes be beneficial and can sometimes be necessary. I know that's hard to hear that
Coming out of the mouth of an alternative practitioner quote unquote, but that's be reasonable
There's times when chemotherapy radiation surgery is the right thing to do
And I think taking a dogmatic position either way is equally wrong
When I hear of an oncologist that poo poo's alternative care and that's the only thing you should do is standards of care
That's speaking out of just pure ignorance
But I also think when you hear an alternative doctor that says I would never do standards of care and chemotherapy just kills people
It's a poison. That's all it does. Well true
It is a poison, but it can kill the cancer and hopefully before it kills the patient and it can
Debalk a cancer when the cancer is actively growing same thing with surgery
Debalking it can be the right thing to do. So don't let anybody tell you what's right or wrong for you
That's a personal decision that you have to make
Upon doing a lot of investigation and talking to a lot of different people. There's wisdom in a multitude of counselors
I think it's best that you have
Counselors that aren't taking a dogmatic approach that are looking at you like an individual and see what's the best thing for you to do
And then of course everybody's advice is going to be biased but take each person's advice from different
categories of health care and then you can balance that out and hopefully bring it to the Lord and know
What is the best approach for you?
So there's benefits of mandates. They're necessary. They can help heal wounds. They can protect us from
Further assault and there's benefits to using that approach with cancer, but it can't be our only thing
If it is we're doomed to just the results
That standards of care are going to give us without digging any deeper
So we want to look at the drawbacks of cancer when we're only going to use a
Therapy for cancer without digging in to what are the causes?
How to clean up the environment?
How to fix the energy and the frequencies behind the scene?
How to fix why the cells are acting that way?
Look at the genetics of the cells not just
Here this gene causes cancer because that usually doesn't exist
But the genetics of metabolism around it so that we can deal with that in a more holistic way
Father, you can take a step back and look at your body and how to correct what's going on in your body and
And why it's happening the better results you're gonna have. It's not a perfect approach. There is not a perfect approach and
If any practitioner tells you that they can cure cancer in some way
I'd run away from them as fast as I could so
But cancer is a complex disease that in fact each cancer is very different
Matter of fact you could say every single person with cancer is a unique disease
So if you look at it that way and you look uniquely at your needs
You're going to get better results
so
We don't want to just throw a bunch of supplements and
Nutraceuticals at a person to try to help them with cancer
That's that's just as wrong as throwing a bunch of drugs at a person to help them with cancer
And we certainly don't want to just get our information about different nutraceutical approaches off of you know
Different media out there because there's a lot of bad information out there
I see different posts on social media that says well if you take
Curcumin or whatever it kills 98% of cancers in the test tube
Well, you know pretty much purified water is gonna kill 98% of cancer cells in a test tube because they'll just die
They don't it's not an delivered environment. So be careful of false claims out there
Be careful of just both face lies out there for the purpose of selling a bunch of supplements
it's misleading at best and
unethical in my book and just be careful of that
I have patients that come to us that are literally taking well over a hundred to two hundred supplements a day
I don't know how your liver could even deal with that. That's not even good for us. So
Take a step back and get as specific as you can find a practitioner that will get specific for you and what your needs are that will do different tests
That's what we're trying to promote. We don't want everybody to come to us
But we want everybody to look at their body differently and uniquely
So that they'll get the best results possible
You have to get to the root you have to get to the cause
There are so many possible causes of cancer
What we're finding today is most causes of cancer are environmental
They're pesticides and chemicals in our environment that even if you're eating organic and doing all the right things
You're still gonna be exposed to these things these get inside the cell and cause the cell to replicate and
In the next coming modules will dig deeper into that and how to deal with that
But you have to deal with those root things
If you really want to change the environment enough to be able to heal the person
So just think about it
Typically our medical profession, you know, you could call it germ theory
But you could call it you know this this theory that there's something wrong with the body and something on the outside
If we injected it into the body or if we do it infusion into the body or if we give a drug to the body
Then we'll fix it without understanding that the terrain the environment of that person
And even that emotional environment in that person is really what you really need to fix
Not that you shouldn't do an injection or that you shouldn't use a supplement or that you shouldn't use a drug
But if you don't clean up the terrain if you don't clean up the environment
We're just not gonna get as good a result
So even if you're choosing you feel like God is leading you to do a standard of care approach
At least add on
The natural things that can dig into cleaning up the environment
Cleaning up your body cleaning up why it's there in the first place dealing with the emotional
wounds that you've had in the past so that you can clean up that fish tank and
You're gonna get the best results possible and even if you do a medical approach that that drug is gonna work better
Under a better environment
That's what our whole idea with these modules is and we're gonna dig deep into it
And give you some really usable advice on how to take those steps
So hold on with us as we go through this
I hope this is gonna be a huge blessing into a lot of people
So you know when everybody can come to us not even
A lot of people don't even have a practitioner dear than they can deal with nor can they even afford a practitioner
That's why we try to make this very reasonable so you could take this information and go with it
So hold on through these modules and we'll see you in module two